let's say you and I are playing a game
where we're trying to figure out how
high a ball is being thrown in the air
or how fast that we're throwing that
ball in the air and what we do is one of
us has a ball and the other one has a
stopwatch over here so this is my best
attempt to it looks more like a cat but
a stopwatch but I think you get the idea
and what we do is one of us throws the
ball and the other one times how long
the ball is in the air and then what we
do is we're going to use that time in
the air to figure out how fast the ball
was thrown straight up and how long it
was in the air or Starion and how high
it got and there's going to be one
assumption I make here and frankly this
is assumption that we're going to make
in all of these projectile motion type
problems is that air resistance is
negligible air resistance is negligible
and for something like if this is a
baseball or something like that that's a
pretty good approximation so we're not
going to get the exact answer and I
could encourage you to experiment on
your own to see or even to see what air
resistance does relative to your
calculations we're going to assume for
this projectile motion and really all of
the future ones or at least in the basic
plate physics playlist we're going to
assume that air resistance is negligible
and what that does for us is that we can
assume that the time up that the time
for the ball to go up to its peak height
is the same thing as the time that it
takes to go down if you look at this
previous video where we plotted
displacement versus time you see after
two seconds the ball went from being on
the ground or I guess the throwers hand
all the way to its peak height and then
the next two seconds it took that same
amount of time to go back down to the
ground which makes sense whatever the
initial velocity is it takes half the
time to go to zero and it takes that
same amount of time to now be
accelerated in the downward direction
back to that same magnitude of velocity
but now in the downward direction so
let's let's play around with some
numbers here just so we get a little bit
more of a concrete sense so let's say I
throw a ball in the air and you measure
using the stopwatch that the ball is in
the air for five seconds so how do we
figure out how fast I threw the ball
well the first thing we can do is we
could say look if the the total time in
the air was five seconds that means that
the time let me
well that means that the change in time
to go up the during the the first half
of I guess the balls time of the year is
going to be 2.5 seconds
and which tells us that over this 2.5
seconds we went from our initial
velocity whatever it was we went from
our initial velocity to our final
velocity which is a velocity of 0 meters
per second in the two and a half seconds
and this isn't the graph for that
example this is the graph for the
previous one I the previous example
where we knew the initial velocity but
in whatever that time is you're going
from your initial velocity to being
stationary at the top right right when
the ball is stationary and then starts
getting increasing velocity in the
downward in the downward direction so it
takes 2.5 seconds to go from some
initial velocity to zero seconds so we
do know what the acceleration of gravity
is we know that the acceleration we know
that the acceleration of gravity here
we're assuming it's constant although
it's slightly not constant but we're
going to assume it's constant we're just
dealing close to the surface of the
earth is negative 9.8 meters meters per
second squared so let's think about it
this our change in velocity our change
in velocity that our change in velocity
is the final velocity minus the initial
velocity which which is the same thing
as zero minus the initial velocity which
is the negative of the initial velocity
and what's another way to think about
change in velocity well just from the
definition of acceleration change in
velocity is equal to acceleration is
equal to acceleration negative 9.8
meters per second squared times time or
times change in time our change in time
we're just talking about the first half
of the ball's time in the air so our
change in time is 2.5 seconds times 2.5
seconds so what is our change in
velocity which is also the same thing as
the negative of our initial velocity get
the calculator out let me get my
calculator bring it onto the screen
so it is it is negative 9.8 meters per
second times 2.5 seconds times 2.5
seconds it gives us negative 24 point 5
negative so this gives us let me write
in a new color this gives us negative 24
point five meters per second this second
cancels out with one of these seconds in
the denominator so we only have one in
the denominator now so it's meters per
second and this is the same thing as our
negative as the negative initial
velocity negative initial velocity
that's the same thing as our change in
velocity and so you multiply both sides
by a negative u we get our initial
velocity so that's simply that simply we
were able to figure out what our
velocity was so literally you take the
time take the total time in the air take
it divide it by 2 and then multiply that
by the acceleration of gravity and if
and if you take s you can take the
absolute value of that or you take the
positive version of that and then that
gives you that gives you your initial
velocity so your initial velocity here
is literally twenty four point five
meters per second and since it's a
positive quantity it is upwards in this
example so that's my initial velocity so
we already figured out part of this game
the whole the initial velocity that I
threw it upwards and that's also going
to be that we're gonna have the same
magnitude of velocity when the ball is
about to hit the ground although it's
going to be in the other direction so
what is the distance or let me make it
clear what is the displacement of the
ball from from its lowest point right
when it leaves your hand all the way to
the peak all the way to the peak well we
just have to remember and once again all
this comes from very straight very
straightforward ideas change in velocity
is equal to acceleration times change in
time and then the other simple idea is
that displacement displacement is equal
to is equal to average velocity average
velocity times change in time now what
is our average velocity our average
velocity is your initial velocity plus
your final velocity divided by two or if
we assume acceleration is constant so
it's literally just the earth
edek mean of your initial and final
velocities so what is that that's going
to be twenty four point five meters per
second plus what's our final velocity in
this situation room we're just going
over the first two point five seconds so
our final velocity is once again zero
meters per second we're just talking
about when we get to this point right
over here so our final velocity is just
zero meters per second and we're just
going to divide that by two this will
give us the average velocity and then we
want to multiply that times two point we
want to multiply that times two point
five times two point five seconds so we
get this part right over here twenty
four point five divided by two we can
ignore the zero that's still is twenty
four point five that gives us twelve
point two five times two point five
times two point five and remember this
right over here is in seconds let me
write the unit's down
so this is 12.25 meters per second times
two point five seconds times two point
five seconds and just to remind
ourselves we are cat we're calculating
the displacement over the first two and
a half seconds so this gives us I'll get
the calculator out once again we have
twelve point two five times two point
five seconds gives us 30 point six two
five so this gives us this gives us so
our displacement is thirty point six two
five thirty point six two five meters
these seconds cancel out meters so
someone this is actually a ton this is
you know roughly give or take about 90
feet thrown in the air so this would be
like a nine story building and I frankly
do not have the arm for that but if
someone is able to throw the ball for
five seconds in the air they have thrown
it thirty meters in the air well
hopefully you found that entertaining in
the next video I'll generalize this
maybe we can get a little bit of a
formula so maybe you can generalize it
so regardless of the measurement of time
you can get the displacement in the air
or even better try to derive it yourself
and we'll see how at least how I tackle
it in the next video